point fr l lundi politique gaël le
dantec
c'est lundi le lundi politique bonjour
yaël l'amour bonjour j'essaie bonjour à
tous cet après midi doit se tenir un
conseil municipal à la plaine des
palmistes un conseil quand
d'incertitudes puisque lors du dernier
conseil le maire s'était retrouvé seul
face à son opposition la chance de sa
propre majorité
nouvel épisode d'une guerre interne qui
pourrait bien à paralyser avec la
commune qu on le maire compte il se
sortir de cette situation
comment en est on arrivé là la commune
est elle victime de pratiques
politiciennes autoritarisme de son maire
de clientélisme
quelle lecture le maire est il de la
situation politique de sa commune
voisine
voici quelques unes des questions que
nous poserons à notre invité nous
parlera également de politique régionale
et nationale de la droite réunionnaise
toujours aussi divisée et les prochaines
échéances électorales marco boyer maire
de la plaine-des-palmistes invité lundi
politique sur la première jusqu'à 13
heures vos questions à partir de 12h45
au 0262 90 2000
marco boyer bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté cette invitation
quelques heures un petit rêve pour moi
avant ce conseil municipal dans d'autres
parlent d'abord qu'on s'arrête sur un
point précis que les discussions la
commune dans la presse ce matin vous
envisagé de détruire l'église actuelle
pour en rembourser nouvelle
je n'envisage rien monsieur le dantec je
fais mon travail d'élu qui doit prendre
en compte les réalités de sa commune
savoir ce qu'il en est des
règlementations du haj des contraintes
de de l'état des services de sécurité
pour trancher sur des questions de
bâtiments à regarder de près étant donné
qu'il s'agit des bâtiments recevant du
public
on n'a pas le droit de les laisser dans
un état qui ne permettrait plus de le
faire il faut vous dire qu'en ce qui
concerne l'église puisque c'est d'elle
qu'il s'agit
ce n'était pas mon programme à pop amon
probant à proprement parler pendant
l'essai pas partie 2
la campagne est en 2014
il se trouve que c'est une réalité que
nous avons découverte et la réalité
c'est quoi c'est que s'il faudrait
l'agrandir revoir sérieusement dans
l'âge de la toiture les équipements
électriques les la circulation
l'accessibilité dans bien dans bien des
points
il ya à revoir le bâtiment tout entier
et ceci a été mis des gens réflexion et
sheila et on avait changé
un groupe un groupe d'étude de faire un
point précis sur la question ce qui est
possible de faire ce qui n'est pas
possible de faire il ya deux
possibilités soit on réhabilite et dans
ces conditions on répare et ce sera
l'église en place pendant que peut-être
les cérémonies se tiendrait ailleurs
momentanément
c'est le cas de figure mais le bâtiment
restera dans sa capacité d'accueil acte
d'accueil actuelle je connais très bien
vous le savez très bien il nous a mis le
savent très bien la plagne que cette
église a été ouverte au début des années
70 et que c'était avec une population de
3400 habitants quand même un peu moins 6
quand je suis arrivé en tant qu élu pour
la première fois mais à l'appel c'était
déjà un près de 3500 3601 même pas
profit de 5 cents mais c'était à peu
près dans cette bien cela est-ce que
excusez moi oui
est ce que c'est à la mairie de décider
de ce qu'on fait d'un édifice religieux
est ce que c'est la mairie se soucier de
la finance au registre il faut bien
comprendre ça parfois le grand public
wallon même nous parlera chien palard
paroissiens la plaine ne le savent pas
il se trouve que c'est un bâtiment
communal dès le départ ç'avait été une
réalisation avec des crédits d'état et
des crédits communaux savent a été aussi
avec une participation de la population
qui étaient concernés et qui avait
appelé le soutien rares soutiens même
financier dans cette affaire c'est un
bâtiment communal et la commune en a
plein responsabilité ce n'est pas une
une bâtiment qui qui appartient à
l'évêché ça n'appartient pas au pape
peut enfin à la papauté ou à quoi que ce
soit à l'organisation
l'organisation cultuelle de l'église
c'est un bâtiment communes et la commune
en pleine responsabilité
elle fait où elle ne fait pas et je vise
à voilà justement on va reparler à la
situation politique
6 si vous étiez en minorité sur ce sujet
précis
cet après midi il est clair que la vie
ne pourra pas être engagée mais je veux
dire que ce sera de la responsabilité de
chacun je pense que les élus qui ont été
choisis du parti culièrement les élus
majoritaires et savait très bien qu'en
ce qui nous concerne
si une situation est proposé pour une
délibération à être votée et s'agit pas
de dire voilà que nous en sommes en
train de nous amuser et de faire de la
paperasserie pour profère la
paperasserie il faut arriver à des
décisions alors la décision devant être
de réhabiliter mais provisoirement point
qu'on 4 en 5 ans 6 ans peut-être une
réhabilitation qui va avoir son coup et
d'allemand ou alençon reconstruction
construction ici pour une adaptation à
la population qui augmente beaucoup à la
plaine des palmistes vous savez que nous
sommes la commune d'une poussée
démographique la plus élevée dans l'île
et ce serait toujours la mairie qui en
était à cheval des choses mais ça ne
peut pas être le diocèse
ça ne peut pas être un groupement
d'église ou je sais pas comment ça
pourrait être organisée où les lois sur
la laïcité
la laïcité ne nous empêche pas
d'intervenir sur des balles qui avaient
été faits dans les années 70 et oui on
dit sur ce genre de bâtiment
la loi n'interdit pas disons de l'inde
intervient sur une propriété qui
assoient et qui reçoit du public
particulièrement j'insiste là dessus en
décembre dernier votre premier adjoint
daniel choisi paris a démissionné ces
déviations qui l'estimé fictives ont
février vous êtes vous la question de
conseil municipal son maintien comme
premier adjoint et majorité s'est
prononcée pour ce maintien et le 28
février dernier vous êtes retrouvé seul
face à votre opposition conseil
municipal sur ces différentes mais
d'abord à quoi vous attendez-vous
ressentent
écoutez je n'ai pas pour habitude de
faire des plans sur la comète
je pense comme à la bourre on appris
mais pardon on fait pas la boire la
pluie mais ouais effectivement de
quelques vrais dysfonctionnements
quelques ce n'est pas des surprises
parce que le premier adjoint et ils ont
été pressenti pour être le candidat de
nom on va y revenir mais pour cet après
midi vous attendez je souhaiterais comme
c'est dit comme c'est connu déjà de tous
les élus l'opposition la vraie
opposition l'ancien co majoritaire qui
toujours majoritaires parfois est
présent mais parfois on le cherche on ne
trouve pas bon c'est un petit peu
disloqué il ya des clans je le conçois
c'est l'année électorale par excellence
et par conséquent pour chacun y va de
son numéro mais je ne sais pas s'ils ont
choisi la bonne voie dans un camp plutôt
que dans un autre
si ce qui est en jeu c'est le budget de
la commune voilà ça veut dire que si tu
votes ça veut dire c'est la préfecture
qui met sous tutelle à coup une
constance et ben ça peut être le cas où
ça peut être aussi le cas où les élus
l'ensemble des élus
ne sont pas mis en dissolution ne sont
pas mis en en annulation le mandat mais
c'est le préfet qui gère en présence des
élus et de responsable d'une délégation
spéciale mais ça peut être aussi le cas
où tous les élus sont mis en situation
d'être démissionnée par décision du
préfet et là c'est seulement la
délégation qui gère avec les points qui
posent administratif tous les élus mais
pas seulement le maire tout envisagé
dans ces cas comme ça ça peut aller dans
un sens comme ça peut aller dans l'autre
mais après monsieur le préfet aura ses
responsabilités dans cette affaire est
le même la plaine des palmistes lui il
est maire jusqu'à nouvel ordre il va
rester en poste
ne serait ce que pour justifier bon ce
qui peut y avoir à utiliser ou pas ce
qui peut être utilisé dans un budget qui
n'est pas voter ou pas bon c'est des
choses comme la mais c'est ce que vous
dites clairement si vous avez pas
l'intention de démissionner on me pose
du tout ça n'a jamais été le cas même si
vous être au mieux la population ne m'a
rien dit dans ce sens et ce n'est pas au
bout de plus d'une trentaine d'années je
le dantec de présence au sein de cette
commune de travail engagé qui n'avait
jamais été fait l'objet bon d'une de
réactions comme celle d'aujourd'hui et
que je vais devoir me remettre en cause
et puis changer les choses on peut pas
donner la roue non plus à des situations
qui ne tiennent pas la route
je veux bien partir mais à condition de
savoir qui viendra à des gersois
concentration des pouvoirs entre voix
qui l'aurait poussée à démissionner de
ses délégations ont également conclu une
critique de la place juge était trop
importante de l'administratif
l'administration de la commune qui
l'enverrait de travail est ce que vous
entendez cette critique
écoutez je l'entends je l'entends mais
je ne comprends pas
parce que depuis 2014 où ces élus là on
accepter de s'engager dans l'intérêt et
de la population dans le sens de
l'action à mener selon un programme que
nous avions établi de travailler en lien
avec un maire qui l'ont élu et qui ont
obtenu eux mêmes leurs responsabilités
respectives de premier deuxième et
adjoints suivant ce ceux là même qui ont
approuvé jusqu'à maintenant jusqu'en
2020 2017 ont approuvé toutes les
orientations qui habitent tous les
dossiers qui ont été présentées toutes
les décisions qu'il fallait prendre et
ils ont été d'accord
et aujourd'hui alors pourquoi on veut
comprendre comprendre pourquoi pas c'est
à dire que vous dites basse et je
confirme j'ai depuis longtemps je n'ai
pas laissé le premier adjoint qui était
mon binôme dans les sélections
départementales
je n'ai pas laissé le premier adjoint
par ailleurs au département être élu au
département sur ma démission
toutes été entendues pour travailler
ensemble pour avancer et aujourd'hui ça
fait fausse route
est ce qu'il y a fait fausse route
excusez moi mais je vais entrer c'est
important un jeune entend j'en entends
beaucoup à la plaine des palmistes et
ailleurs dans la presse et tout
enfin je me découvre parfois à être un
homme nouveau un homme différent dans
quand je lis quand j'entends parler
ailleurs écriture à jeudi mais ça est
toujours cherché à faire en lien avec
les élus avec les services avec eux les
services d'état laissé les collectivités
territoriales tout est connu tout a été
approfondi tout a dit approuver et est
aujourd'hui bon ce n'est plus cas est ce
que daniel warnier n'est plus
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il a fait un
manque de
d'une grande différence par rapport à ce
qu'il devait être
et par rapport à ce qu'il est devenu et
depuis quand est ce qu'il n'est plus
avantagés à 16 heures suivi j'ai déjà
dit ce n'est pas encore dans les
dernières déclarations qui se font bon
que l'un des prises de position qui là
que ma voix pourra être tenu mais voit
aussi un art encore quelques-unes il se
dit que vous soutiendriez plutôt se fier
aux élus à la mairie de titres
j'entends ça aussi beaucoup madame
sophie nadal est une dame candidate
j'ai tellement possible et c'est une
administrée également et c'est une
arnaque à économique dans la plaie mais
les responsables du tourisme et vous la
soutiendriez je la connais très bien
elle est élue à adjointe à daniel
gonthier c'est une dame engagé à droite
dans la poissonnerie vous pensez bien
que ça n'a jamais changé
par conséquent tout ma majorité était
sensiblement même ou plutôt à droite est
un bien qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui
avait des sensibilités peut-être
différent tous rapprochés mais qui était
toujours l'abrogation communal alors
aujourd'hui si il s'agit surtout de
parny si pas ni ne pas s'entendre avec
sofiane hasard les deux candidats droite
de droite
mieux connue sur la plaine dans leur
éthique jarry est très précisément vous
soutiendrez qui si jamais ça continue
comme ça je pense que si madame anjalay
candidate vraiment officiellement
désigné jeu
est-ce que vous soutenez plus tôt elle
s'est ensuite bien sûr à toutes les
positions que je vois naître dans la
plaine des palmistes
ça ne sent pas une position favorable à
ceux qui m'ont toujours combattu ce ne
sera pas une position non plus favorable
ceux qui sont restés dans leur
engagement politique que incertain je
serai toujours mois dans le camp de ceux
qui défendent mais option mes valeurs
mais mes orientations politiques majeurs
pour la récole à plein pour la réunion
pour l'état l'ensemble national
ça n'a jamais changé mais je le dantec
vous avez comme comme d'autres élus
étaient la cible de les jeunes qui ont
beaucoup dit que les élus ne faisait pas
correctement leur travail n'étaient pas
jugées comme étant des représentants
dans la critique de la politique telle
qu'elle se pratique parfois il ya aussi
et beaucoup la critique du favorise ni
favoritisme en politique vous avez été
contraint de miser neuf agents d'autres
communes dans les contrats en europe et
en france je vous assure que vous avez
sanctionnés vous comprenez que ça passe
plus c'est toujours de boutiques
je ne sais pas mais moi je fais mon
travail je ne suis pas condamner pour
m'en parler d'un dea fait justice voulue
par mes adversaires
la justice applique la loi telle que la
conçoit tels que je pense pas de
l'occurrence la justice a estimé que
vous aviez sanctionné pour politique que
je suis pas beaucoup de dirigeants de
légende de situations financier ça ça
c'est vous que vos c'était votre des
forces et mon avis on l'a dit un bike a
admis la justice la justice défend
toujours le parti des agents et qui
n'ont pas eu satisfaction à col de
renouvellement politique ou de roulement
au renouvellement de responsables
ça se voit partout ça se voit pas tout
et les choix des agents se font à
travers les compétences qui peuvent
avoir les engagements tu peux avoir pour
servir la politique générale de la
commune portée voulue par un maire ou un
président ou
de collectivités ou par un responsable
du verre ou là où ils se trouvent
eh bien je fais mon travail j'ai
considéré que la structuration des
services n'était plus envisageable avec
ed est ce que ces trois ans est tombé à
semoy zone et ç'avait été constaté que
des les embauches avaient été faites en
2013 en 2013 alors que les élections
étaient en 2014 et shalit et j'avais été
des recrutements sur des missions qui
n'étaient pas vraiment avéré mais avec
des salaires très mi-robot mirobolants
j'ai eu bien qu'il voulait mettre un peu
d'ordre là dedans mais il avait ça a été
fait dans le respect de la législation
parce que les gars vous avez donné que
vous avez viré des agents qui est créé
par votre prédécesseur
comment est-ce qu'on sort de ceux de ce
cycle infernal de jeunes et je pense
qu'un prédécesseurs avant moi avait eu
l'occasion d'amener peut être beau mais
en fait je n'avais pas fait de
recrutement déjà juste l'année précédant
les élections et il avait lui-même mis
de côté au même moment est-ce qu'on sort
qu'ils n'avaient pas renouveler bondé
contre un poids des personnes qui était
soi disant plus proche de marco boyer
même dans la campagne
ou alors aux dents dans l'action
communale ces sites ils ont droit
moi je n'ai pas changé je suis pas un
homme de justice un d'aller au combat de
justice en permanence vous savez ça me
fait 29 peut être jusqu'à maintenant sur
toutes ces affaires se lève naufrage il
ya eu ces affaires dernièrement des
affaires de personnel albert salle
communale j'assume
j'assume mais je gère la commune dans
son d'une organisation qui doit être
mise en place pour qu'elles soient
opérationnelles et pour qu'elle soit
efficace
selon nos confrères du gir des enquêtes
préliminaires seraient en cours pour des
irrégularités concernant la vente de
voiture l'a connue ou encore un chemin
privé d'étonner
offredo fra mairie vous attendez j'en
connais c'est plus que moi je suis au
travail je n'ai pas reçu de convocation
mais ces affaires qui vous parle que
vous avez une idée de course je sais
d'où ça vient et je sais comment les
choses viennent quand ils font les
belles électorale et quand il s'agit de
tous c'est aussi à cette occasion que
les discréditer l'action d'un maire la
situation des mères la nature à la mer
sur serre la main sur ces affaires là
vous dit il n'y a pas de souci elle
avait absolument un peu entièrement
il ya aussi avoir couru du conseil
municipal augmentation des indemnités
dès cette période critique beaucoup
d'éthique eux s'en sont trop payés
ces brevets a pas de moment plus
privilégiés plus choisis pour faire
passer ce qui est la règle la règle ce
qui a eu un décret du ministère pour un
botté hausses allaient à des élus de
l'ain 10022 à 1027 st550 pour que le
maire de l'appel des maires et c'est ce
qu'il a fait a dit l'adjoint et c'est
aussi la sphère des cons c'est miss pau
qui ont des délégations
alors en ce qui concerne le maire de la
plaine ça va faire 90 euros annuels a
pas eu l bond de 7 alors moi je ne
cherche pas ce gars je suis d'accord que
les clauses amical désapprouvent
mais il va déjà prouvé le préfet qui lui
est tenu de dire aux conseils municipaux
divers qui lie à le décret ministériel
et que vous devez le mettre en
application à la décision ne vient pas
de moi je n'ai pas tiré sur mon but est
de faire en sorte que je gagne 90 euros
annuels dans l'année
de plus voilà la situation s'est
vraiment
un peu clochemerle tout ça s'étale à
paris à l'elysée donc sortir du
clochemerle vous êtes allé rencontrer
avec les autres maires de la réunion
qu'est ce que vous aviez envie de lui
dire dans ce grand débat national
alors là aussi ça avait été un petit peu
la polémique du coin tout est sujet à
polémique
bon il était parti pour le rencontrer et
depuis 9h30 les élus réunionnais se sont
retrouvés entre eux à midi se sont
retrouvés avec madame busan l'ami
giradin déjeuner un rassemblement déjà
avec ceux de guadeloupe de martinique et
pato les quatre points de leur mère vous
avez vous n'avez pas pu vous exprimer
mais en dehors de cette polémique qu'est
ce que vous aviez envie de lui dire moi
je lui aurais dit et même avec un petit
passage en poésie vous pensez bien que
il y à des interventions de l'état qui
peut être discutable
il y assure toute tentation de
l'application en matière
environnementale par exemple pour
l'utilisation de terrains où il ne
faudrait pas qu'il y ait la plus petite
espèce à préserver qu'il faut absolument
protéger et qu on aurait pu protéger
qu'une autre façon mais en utilisant le
terrain qui a été acquis par la commune
et qui restent sur les bras
aujourd'hui il ya des orientations de
lois environnementales qui sont disons
contraignantes
on parle de quoi précisément cette
histoire de terrain c'est quoi ben vous
avez un terrain et le tissu le terrain
il y a un projet d'intérêt public
un équipement sportif ou alors un parent
angkor wat
il faut le nettoyer il faut l'aménager
il faut l'équipe est bon et se trouve
qu'après vous voyez les rennais ses
habilités à venir non monsieur vous ne
pouvez pas y aller oui il faut qu'ils
restent en l'état
en l'état pur il faut pas qu'il y ait le
petit muguet ou la petit taureau qui dès
qu'ils disparaissent dans la zone et
puis finalement ben le terrain je te
l'aï dit on ne fait pas on ne fait pas
c'est quand même
lallaing possibilité aux élus
d'aujourd'hui bon disons de faire
avancer des choses qui sont qui sont
quand même défendable dans le grand
débat national qui a été lancé il ya
aussi localement des dix initiatives
pour tenter de répondre à cette crise
des zizou est ce que les réponses de la
région gel des taxes sur les carburants
avec la création d'un conseil
consultatif
c'est plutôt de l'autre des pistes qui
vous semblent intéressantes et est ce
que ce grand déballage
c'est une bonne piste il faut aller dans
tous les sens là vous savez je ne serai
pas en mesure actuellement est mal placé
pour parler des orientations des
décisions de la région ou du département
vous avez la vie vous savez dans sa
communauté de communes bien sûr que j'ai
envie j'ai un avis je considère
qu'aujourd'hui le débat doit être
engagée pour savoir exactement dans à
travers les des réclamations qui sont
faites ici là il ya eu arrêt entre
autres avec les gilet jaune qui sont
organisées comme on le sait eh bien il
faudrait avoue savoir exactement ce
qu'ils demandent est ce qui est possible
d'attribuer vous les avez entendus
ben je les entends mais je ne suis pas
président de région pour savoir qu'il
faut qu'il faut jouer sur le carburant
ou jouer sur d'autres
d'autres marques comme de manoeuvre ou
d'autres dépenses qu'il faudrait peut
être supprimé il ya eu beaucoup d'action
qui ont été faites il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont engagés je trouve que la
politique du général de la région en
lien avec les communes aussi nous sommes
largement soutenu à ce niveau là aussi
on voit rien la lauter la nouvelle route
du littoral
bon les interventions pour les étudiants
les l'intervention pour les familles
réunionnaises qui veulent aller en de la
continuité territoriale toute façon mis
en place c'est la politique de la région
mêlant si on supprime certaines choses
c'est pour donner autre chose donner
autre chose
excuse c'est dans l'intérêt supérieur de
la réunion vous savez j'ai été formé à
l'école du général de gaulle quand
j'étais plus jeune c'était cela
l'objectif faire en sorte qu'il y ait
assez revient une grande cause
faire en sorte que l'intérêt général
prime sur les intérêts particuliers et
au niveau des jus les jeunes je suis
malheureux c'est malheureux de le dire
je suis malheureux de constater que
constater il se trouve que ça tient dans
tous les sens
parfois il y à ce qu'on demande n'est
pas fois il ya aussi le contraire de ce
qu'on demande avec d'autres amis bon il
faudra y mettre de l'ordre
globalement il ya deux grands points qui
sortent ces discussions c'est d'abord le
pour achat il ya des gens qui ne vivent
pas que le et l'autre par la démocratie
locale si mon souci jeu ces deux thèmes
je vois le constat que le pourra d'achat
ce n'est pas seulement la fin de la
région ce n'est pas seulement la fin du
département il faut s'adresser aux
entreprises qui est ce qu'il veut c'est
la fin de tout le monde le pouvoir
d'achat c'est aussi bons les
possibilités à chacun de se donner les
moyens d'agir selon ce qu'ils souhaitent
mais aussi d'agir avec les moyens qu'il
a que je ne peux pas être autrement que
cela je les fais pendant que ma vie de
sa manière et je me suis donné la
possibilité de faire ce que j'avais à
faire mais je suppose que tout le monde
devrait envisager
je vois qu'ils dial parmi les
les jeunes des chefs d'entreprise il y à
aussi bondée et personnes qui sont dans
l'administration et qui rompt le travail
qu'ils ont leur le salaire mais c'est et
c'est un statut ici là wyeth dans une
entreprise ou ailleurs mais ce qu'on
fait pour ça doit être amélioré je dis
pas non mais ce n'est pas seulement la
sphère de l'état
ce n'est pas seulement la sphère des
collectivités c'est la fête de tous à
illies à des syndicats aujourd'hui on
est à se demander si les syndicats
peuvent encore intervenir dans ce
domaine
ou alors il faut faire de la surenchère
accepter les surenchères tout le temps
tout temps et ce sera limité dans les
possibilités d'intervention dans l'est
dans les réponses apportées par la
ministre annick girardin et il ya un
surcroît de près dé débloquer est-ce que
ça c'est une bonne piste
est-ce que vous en tant que maire on dit
c'est une bonne façon de lutter contre
contre le chômage contre la précarité
contre c'était mieux déjà que ce qui
avait été mise en oeuvre dès l'arrivée
de monsieur le président la république
il se trouve que c'était des contrats
descendirent à 50 poissons de prise en
charge sur des niveaux horaires de
environ 90 91 eur il n'y avait pas
tellement le choix d'améliorer les
choses
c'est possible au niveau des communes de
prendre cette part entendu avec l'état
et avec aussi un accompagnement communal
pour amener l'employé l'ouvrier le
l'agent au niveau des cent cinquante et
une heure c'est à dire dans le salaire
du smig
c'est pour ces messieurs à ce moment là
à la change entière de la collectivité
et c'est partout pareil les colistiers
pourront faire dans cet état mais le
propre affaire pour les attentes de tout
le monde vous avez à la plaine des
palmistes y aurait bien des jarres
s'occuper du cas de 300 à 350 personnes
demandeurs de 2
de contrat alors quand ce n'est pas
possible il ya aussi le passage devant
le pôle emploi pour déterminer les
compétences laissées bien que ça passe
par pôle emploi et que ce soit plus
simple si c'est au moins clair c'est au
moins clair on amenuise le risque de
clientélisme politique c'est tellement
certainement qu'il devait y en avoir
moi je n'ai jamais joué dans ce sens il
fallait prendre en compte les situations
sociales si vous ont été pris à une
époque quelqu'un qui avait été nommé
dans une école à ben justement revenons
aussi dans l'école et il y avait eu le
choix du rectorat de l'administration
rectorale de désigner ou de nommer une
personne dans une école pour s'occuper
d'enfants handicapés
ni la famille ni l'entrée le corps
enseignant ni la mairie qui doit faire
partie d'un comité pour statuer sur
l'appel à la vérité c'est à ce titre que
moi je m'étais élevé contre une position
qui avait surpris il n'y avait pas des
notions politiques et c'était il y avait
une situation il ya toujours une
situation politique mais ce n'était pas
le fait de vouloir faire que cette
personne soit recruté par le rectorat
je suis d'accord mais recruter peut-être
dans un autre établissement moi je veux
bien mais recruter la même dans
l'établissement alors qu'elle avait
injurié elle avait presque agressé bien
souvent verbalement
bon les agents qui était et qu'il
comprenait plus rien avec les familles
elles mêmes il ya eu un soulèvement
familial on m'a dit seulement qu kim
boyer qui avait organisé ça je suis le
mouvement
je reconnais que ç'avait été un petit
peu une situation dépassé s'est passé
déjà en route communale cette affaire on
va lui dire que lavage avait fait de la
diffamation et ira et le tribunal avait
déjà statué là dessus reconnaissant le
fait que bon il devait y avoir un non
lieu ça c'est la décision de justice
il est je ne la commenterai pas bien sûr
je me suis défendu il est 12h 46m est un
peu plus de dix minutes de démission
marco boyer
si vous avez des questions à poser à
monsieur le maire 02 62 99 2000
marcouyre est toujours où la vie était
un militant de droite c'est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes toujours droite
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
je ne dois plus jamais je ne vois pas
très bien en quoi bon les situations qui
ont été connus dans les dernières
échéances électorales et même bien avant
dans toute l'histoire de policiers que
j'ai connu je ne vois pas très bien qu
est ce qui pourrait peut-être remplacer
des valeurs qui ont été jouées qui est
défendu et qui correspond totalement à
ma façon de voir les choses pour la
plaine pour la réunion pour la france je
n'ai jamais varié d'un iota
je ne suis pas une valseuses je ne suis
pas quelqu'un qui change de bord ou
d'étiquettes ou de palau
à chaque mouvement de foule je serai
dans mon axe mais à travailler il faut
une cause qui est supérieur vol qui dans
l'intérêt général
et c'est cela ma mamma votre motivation
aujourd'hui je suis bien avec le shit
bien avec l'entrée ils se retrouvent par
voie oui enfin le maire a donné lundi là
depuis quelque temps se retrouve pas du
tout vous allez voir qu'ils vont devoir
est aussi eux aussi s'organiser
s'entendre pour pour leurs propres
intérêts et puis pour 1-2 des secteurs
responsables it et qu'ils ont et paul
intérêts de la réunion toute entière
moi je ne pense pas que les choses se
passent mieux dans les divisions
j'en parle en connaissance de cause
quand on sait ce qu'il se fasse à la
plaine ca va dans tous les sens et ça ne
fait pas avancer les choses ça fait des
conseils municipaux qui se succèdent qui
est des personnes montées et par
conséquent bon ça ne fait pas gagner du
terrain à quoi que ce soit et surtout
c'est au détriment des populations que
nous représentons qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qui les divise aujourd'hui est ce qu'il
ya une autre show d'idées
vous pourriez entendre une histoire de
goût sans doute sans doute il faudrait
peut-être lui a posé la question qu'est
ce qui fait que vous êtes plutôt contre
ce monsieur ou vous l'a trop monsieur
pourquoi il est contre lot et instituts
d après ils font des groupes et puis ce
sont ceux qui sont au milieu qui sont
peut-être un petit peu plus gêné à cette
affaire il faut convenir que monsieur
fontaine et la une en responsabilité de
droite au niveau d'un parti national
c'est le patron auquel j'adhère
dirigeante
donc je suis tout à fait en lien avec
lui un jour dit robert est aussi est
aussi quelqu'un connu points de vente
c'est comme ça que il avait été reconnu
à la plaine des palmistes et soutenue et
par conséquent il fait un travail à la
région qui est dans le sens aussi des
situations voulu assez proche d'une
politique de la politique de deux ans à
vous ça vous gêne il faudrait savoir si
tu es monsieur le président la
république dans un colloque voulez-vous
le situer où vous la gigue et la tienne
sa responsabilité de président il fait
et c'est bon croit-il pas le droit d'un
conte qui après je suis pas comme on
appelle ça aujourd'hui d'une république
en marche
j'ai toujours été dans la république qui
devait marcher dans une république qui
devait avancer et j'étais dans la
république quand il y avait monsieur
mitterrand j'étais dans l'armée je ne
suis pas miterrandiste et je ne suis pas
socialiste mais mais mais mais mais
j'étais pour reconnaître le bien-fondé
cantier c'est bon et le mal fondé quand
c'est mauvais et actuellement où vous
dire dès qu'il ya du bien je dis qu'il
ya des choses qui sont bonnes en tout
cas il est courageux
en tout cas il a a du répondant et il a
le sens de l'explication et de la
communication ce que la plaine des
palmistes devrait avoir davantage je le
conçois n'empêche que je ne peux pas le
fixer dans un camp comme dans l'autre il
y a un premier ministre qui est
notoirement connu comme ayant été un
projet piste par conséquent du camp de
d'une droite que je soutenais plus plus
spontanément plus sincèrement je pense
que monsieur monsieur le premier
ministre n'a pas peut-être non plus
changé son cap sur l'essentiel de
politique à conduire ou alors en tant
que maire ou en tant que premier
ministre
vous aviez vous aviez un peu de tout
l'essentiel vous n'aviez pas appelé à
voter
je n'ai pas bm a voté manuel mâcon ça ne
veut pas dire que voilà je ne souhaitais
pas qu'ils épousent ddd des suffrages
qui lui soit contraire il y a eu une
expression plus générale pour madame le
pen pour monsieur mélenchon pour
d'autres candidats qui se sont
éparpillés un petit peu jusqu'au dernier
et marine le pen je voyais à peu près ce
qui allait se passer et j'ai fait mon
parti de voter en connaissance de cause
dans la situation présente d'époque et
étant donné que je n'étais h moment-là
que seulement un électeur
c'est pas en tant que mère que je vais
prendre une position pour un parti que
je ne connais pas tant d'un côté que de
l'autre
ce n'était pas en tant que maire que
j'avais moins organisés je n'étais pas
mandatés pour cela organiser la campagne
électorale d'un candidat ou de l'autre
il ya eu des expressions diverses la
plaine des palmistes aja a joué le rôle
de citoyen comme ça s'est passé dans
toutes les communes de l'île et je
n'avais pas dépassé ce stade vous
vous sentez en phase avec la ligne de
laurent wauquiez
je ne suis pas opposé sur bon nombre de
points je n'ai plus l'occasion
malheureusement pour des raisons
personnelles de santé
bon je n'ai plus eu l'occasion
d'assister au grand meeting au
rassemblement au grand congrès bon à
paris ou ailleurs mais je suis adhérent
aux républicains je suis quelqu'un de
discipliné
on sait très bien qu étant républicains
au oprah tiré puis conduit aujourd'hui
conduit aujourd'hui pendant par wauquiez
ils savent très bien que je ne pourrais
pas être sa bille qui du jour au
lendemain se retrouvera un côté bon de
mécanique de même d'un ami greg pour
penser aux rsa général de la france
voici finalement pas absolument un mot
sur ces municipales qui est qui qui a
acquis cet après midi globalement on a
100 ce moment là que vous êtes entré
seul ce c'est vous dites c'est un
rebondissement ou est ce que c'est la
fin de l'ère boyer la boyet commencé à
finir dès qu'elle a rongé puisque
j'avais déjà très clairement un signe
souligné le fait que j'assumais la
responsabilité de cette mandature
j'ai été honorée de la conduire tant
qu'il y avait tout le groupe majoritaire
côtés et même au delà
parce qu'un autres groupes politiques du
conseil municipal soit disant
l'opposition votent en permanence avec
nous ça s'est passé très bien jusqu'à il
ya quatre ans et aujourd'hui bon c'est
un petit peu la débandade et ça va dans
tous les sens il ya des clans quoi
est-ce que vous allez finir ce monde et
paisiblement mieux le dantec
je voudrais rassurer la les amis pape
benoît je suis toujours attaché sa
village
je n'ai plus de démonstration à faire là
dessus je suis attaché à tous ceux qui y
sont et avec lesquels je discute très
aimablement et courtoisement très
régulièrement rim et il va vous allez
avoir un souci de jeu
c'est à dire pas de majorité appliquer
les lois qui s'impose c'est à dire c'est
à dire que s'il n'y a plus de
possibilité de voter un budget s'il ya
plus de possibilité de décider quoi que
ce soit en lien avec une majorité d'élus
au sein du conseil municipal qui en
assureront aussi le pardon la position
diverses et bien que je comprendrais ils
font comme ils veulent comme ils
l'entendent et bien mais ça sera connu
et démontrer à monsieur le préfet que
c'est à lui maintenant de de pondre eux
de prendre la responsabilité du deux
vignes de la plaine et si vous ce qu'est
ce qu'il faut pas ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est que s'ils manquent
auboyer à la suite de cela arrive à ne
plus pouvoir exercer son mandat de maire
en lien avec une majorité il faut bien
que ça se passe ainsi
eh bien il devra partir mais il devra
partir en même temps que monsieur
barnier regroupent en même temps que
monsieur payet son goût prend même temps
messieurs st lambert son groupe hole et
dissidents divers et le groupe
c'est tout le monde qui partira il y
aura pas de changement de maire pas
uniquement à cause de de gesticulations
du moment comme comme celle que nous
connaissons est ce que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut bien l'impression un groupe
qui disent ok vous restez mer on vous a
pu mais à condition façon et c'est un
peu que je peux être dans ce genre de
tractations et de 20 ans jean de
désordre démocratique
la tomate démocratie s'exerce partout
joly il ya même de l'assuas démocratie
ou bien c'est vous le et d'autre je suis
élu maire cette liste pour un avec une
groupe avec une majorité qui a été élu
pour qu'elles méliz mais ils feraient
pas de compromis pour je n'ai pas fait
de faute de gestion
après les ressentis des uns et des
autres je ne peux pas non plus les
empêcher on me dit voilà que je suis
dans le dysfonctionnement il faudrait me
le démontrer
dysfonctionnements ce quelque chose qui
est bloquant qui est gênant peut-être
que certains voudraient être mère à la
place du maire aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
embaucher comme ils veulent
pour pouvoir dépenser comme ils veulent
pour pouvoir orienter peut-être toute
politique comme ils veulent
ben pour l'instant ce n'est pas tout à
fait le 10e j aime le dessin que j'avais
choisi affaire à suivre donc
dans les heures qui viennent merci marco
boyer d'avoir été notre invité dans
l'indie politique aujourd'hui devant à
la même heure ce sera le club de la
presse passé une excellente journée sur
la première
comme l'été indien
[Musique]